قبل بضعه ايام وبتغريده من ثلاث كلمات
حذرت نائبه رئيس المفوضيه الاوروبيه للقيم
والشفافيه تويتر من الحظر في الاتحاد
الاوروبي قائله وداعا ايها الطائر تحذير
يبدو انه قريب من التطبيق بحق الطائر
الازرق
لقد اختار تويتر الطريقه الصعب اختار
المواجهه من خلال الخروج من مدونه ممارسات
التضليل الاوروبيه الطبيعيه التي تضع
القواعد الاساسيه لقانون الاتحاد بشان
الخدمات الرقميه المدونه التي اعلنت تويتر
نيته الانسحاب منها كان الاتحاد الاوروبي
قد اطلقها عام 2018 حيث ستدخل حيز التنفيذ
في 25 من اغسطس لاجبار المنصات على مكافحه
المعلومات المضلله اذ تنص على وجه الخصوص
بوجوب ازاله المحتوى غير القانوني وحظر
الاعلانات التي تستهدف القاصرين وبفرض
غرامات تصل الى سته في المئه من حجم
الاعمال على المنصات التي لا تم هذه
القواعد
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتبر المدونه بمثابه
ميثاق لمكافحه المعلومات المضلله في
الفضاء الالكتروني حيث وقع عليه ما يقرب
من 30 موقعا من بينها مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الكبرى مثل ميته وتويتر وتيك
توك الى جانب جوجل ومايكروسوفت التهديد
بالحظر لم يكن الاول على لسان جروفا فقد
سبقها الى ذلك الوزير الفرنسي المفوض
للشؤون الرقميه الا ان الاخير اعرب عن
قلقه بشان التنظيم الاوروبي المفرط في
مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي في المستقبل معتبرا
موقف البرلمان الاوروبي مبالغا فيه لكونه
يفرض التزامات تدقيق والتزامات شفافيه
مفرطه بالنسبه لهذا النوع من النماذج وبين
التهديد بالحظر وتطبيقه قرابه ثلاثه اشهر
امام الطائر الازرق للتغريد في السماء
الاوروبيه تغريد ان سكت سيؤثر على نقاشات
الراي العام بحسب الوزير الفرنسي لكن الم
علومات المضلله تهديد للديمقراطيه
الاوروبيه
لمتابعه المزيد
تقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات